the california recall is heating up with
one week to go
voters in the golden state will decide
whether they've had enough of rampant
homelessness crime and coveted mandates
and boot gavin newsom from office
democrats wrapping up attacks on the
leading republican candidate larry elder
a newsome rally speaker even called
elder quote a black face on white
supremacy the candidates taking aim at
each other
this man has been an absolute disaster
the quality of our schools has declined
homelessness is up cost of living is up
forest mismanagement water mismanagement
and people as i mentioned are leaving
california for the very first time let
me tell you a little bit about mr elder
he is to the right
of donald trump
he would make honestly donald trump
blush
all right so this is this is the segment
that you wanted to talk about before
so oh it's about skin color yeah great
donald trump lush all right well so they
can't stop so what do you ask me a
question
can i get the question
okay it's the fact that they're saying
that larry elder is a
three examples of this and it's it's
hilarious to see liberals attack people
over skin color in order to protect the
most white
privileged politician in modern history
elder i'm not his consultant he should
go after gavin newsom about being white
like what would happen because they're
going after him about being black he
should have fun and go you you sir are
extremely white you know and you and you
are the white face of stupidity but you
know white supremacist now is the new
uncle tom if you are black and dare to
challenge the party ideology or dare to
leave their ideological race-driven
plantation you will now be called a
black-faced white supremacist again
while ignoring the virginia governor you
know the canadian prime minister a late
night comedian god knows who else who
who actually did blackface and were
white
you know one of the most significant
consequences of this race and they say
right now dana that uh
that gavin newsom appears may win but
you know larry elders within striking
distance is what he has said about
senator dianne feinstein oh right
because um
well senator dianne feinstein has said
she's not going anywhere but apparently
all the democrats are like ooh like what
count in the days like maybe she's going
to go somewhere and so they're hoping
that
the democrats are saying oh well if
larry elder or another republican wins
and they're the governor and she dies
then he gets to appoint another
republican and that'll be the end of the
senate um so one it's offensive to
dianne feinstein and so now not only are
they talking about racial issues about
sexism and it's just awful but did you
notice in the comments when we said that
they were going back and forth with each
other larry elder was making all policy
arguments yeah and gavin newsom made
only personal attacks and so i think
that's one of the reasons that the
californians that are wanting to vote
newsom out
are thinking about it i don't love the
recall process i don't think it's great
but i understand why people are
frustrated in california
however i do think when it was announced
i think it was announced today that
president biden is going to go and
campaign for gavin and gavin newsom i
believe that they must they must feel
that gavin newsom is going to win and
then biden's team will say see he's not
a drag on the party he's fine right yeah
you agree with that i do it was a coin
flip until about three weeks ago and
then the democrats really started to
panic and the unions in hollywood poured
about 10 million into this race just at
the same time the press started savagely
attacking his race his divorces and his
taxes like you said all personal smears
nothing to do with policy now it's
really kind of a tough reach for them
but if i was running this campaign i
would make it about management you can't
manage the forest you can't manage the
water you can't manage energy keep it
about management because clearly
democrats cannot manage that state well
in addition to that there's some kind of
trillion dollar fraud going on in the
state unemployment uh division in
california but
it's interesting that there's talking
about it being an attack on their values
if someone like larry elder comes in and
on social justice
look i the great french a great french
philosopher once said that
that phrase has never been used on the
show
it's nothing like the specter of the
death penalty to focus one's mind and
gavin newsom has gotten very focused
here to your point democrats have
realized you lose this seat here this
would be an earthquake a political
earthquake unlike i've seen in 20 years
gavin newsom has come under criticism i
think for the high taxes the crime the
homelessness population going to the
french laundry and but that was that was
the catalyst that's what allowed i think
that the floodgates come but republicans
i think may have caught themselves might
have might not have thought this thing
could have gotten as serious as that
because i think if they thought that
they might have ran some more serious
candidates larry elder i don't have any
opposition to him because of his race i
just i'm just not sure he's serious
enough and qualified enough to be
governor of california i think voters
out there will make that determination i
would agree with you dana it it's
unfortunate that the clip we showed
showed newsom attacking him on personal
issues i i think personal issues should
not someone's personal life like that
should not be involved in politics and
frankly newsom should be challenged on
policy as elder should be but
unfortunately politics has gone to a bad
place but we like to just attack people
well and you know what
and it works for some people and that's
why they do it and then some people
arnold pulled it off want to